By definition, mass is the quantity of matter
that a body contains.
But, could there be negative mass?
That seems counterintuitive right?
How can you have negative two kilograms of
something...
Negative mass seems to violate the laws of
our universe…
But, in 2014 a couple of excited researchers
did some calculations and found it was A-OKAY.
The Universe is fine with negative mass as
long as that mass isn't’ solid.
If it’s a fluid, you’re cool.Science pun.
So…
Negative mass can exist.
According to their calculations, a perfect
fluid -- which doesn’t exist -- would allow
negative mass to exist and wouldn’t defy
the laws of general relativity!
I know that’s complicated, but put a pin
in that for a second.
Because just recently in 2017…
Researchers used a superfluid to create something
with “effectively” negative mass.
In spite of what the media is saying (even
in the university's own press release)
the researchers never said they created negative
mass.
Instead, the actual paper says they created
“negative effective mass”
What really happened, as I understand it,
they created a Bose-Einstein condensate that
behaves unexpectedly,
k
moving in a way that makes it seem like or
that is similar to something with negative
mass -- but it doesn’t actually have negative
mass.
Sidebar:
This is a problem in science journalism, it’s
easy to get excited and miss a key detail.
In science (and journalism) details matter.
This has been said by you all in the comments,
by other science communicators, and even John
Oliver.
Science is hard.
End sidebar.
With that in mind, again.
This isn’t negative mass, it’s a Bose-Einstein
condensate that behaves as if it had negative
mass.
As in when this superfluid moves it does so
in an unexpected way.
But it does have mass, the superfluid was
made of 10,000 rubidium 87 isotopes -- so
it has the mass of that.
Get it?
Totally.
But c’mon, I know you’re all nerds out
there, but you didn’t tune in to learn about
how a trapped supercooled superfluid behaved
weirdly... so that closes that.
Now, remember that pin… let’s snag it.
What if they had created negative mass?
What would it be like?
What would it look like?
ALL THE WHAT?!
To be honest, no one really knows.
Negative mass was first theorized by Einstein
early in the last century while coming up
with general relativity.
A handful of essays published in the 1950s
coined the idea of negative mass, as an opposite
to positive mass.
So, scientifically, it’s a relatively new
concept.
Some of the papers say something made of negative
mass would still have momentum, and be subject
to some limits of physics, but would also
violate Newton’s Third Law of motion, the
equal and opposite reaction one.
If you pushed a weight made of negative mass,
it would move toward you.
But, I read one 1986 article by John G. Cramer,
a physics professor at the University of Washington
-- and he described it like this:
“Consider a pair of equal and opposite positive
and negative mass[es] placed close to each
other,” he wrote.
“The negative mass is attracted to the positive
mass, while the positive mass is repelled
by the negative mass.
Thus, the two masses will experience equal
forces and accelerations in the same direction
(in violation of Newton's third law) and the
system of two particles will accelerate, seemingly
without limit.
The negative mass will chase the positive
mass with constant acceleration.”
In either scenario, shiz is gettin’ weird.
If you’re being pedantic, negative mass
would be impossible, because no mass equals
no matter at all; but pedantry aside, what
negative mass seems to mean is matter out
of the constraints of one of the bonds of
the universe.
It makes sense that something like this would
excite science journalists, I just hope we
are positive next time.
Okay, i’ll stop.
The more we understand about particle physics,
the better we're gonna understand the universe
itself.
To that end, we do have a video about how
black holes and gravitational waves could
potentially help us find dark matter and you
can watch it here.
Does this video hurt your brain?
Cause it totally hurt my brain while I was
making it.
Let us know down in the comments, make sure
you subscribe for more Seeker and thanks for
watching.